hi so today dr. Goswami and I will be
presenting our recent work regarding the
application of molecular diagnostics to
stay in psychology smears I will present
the clinical relevant parts pertaining
to obtaining psychologic material choice
of lesions and Joseph mutations and the
result well dr. BIR Swami will focus on
the particular methodology used to
detect this molecular alteration so the
learning objectives of today are to
understand the processing of
psychological samples and how it relates
to molecular diagnostics we will go over
the benefits of using psychology smears
for molecular diagnostics than the
details of compliant technology and
briefly mentioned the potential for use
of psychology samples for development of
future molecular applications so method
the method of obtaining tissue samples
by cytology from solid lesions it's
called fine needle aspiration or FNA
ethanai is a minimally invasive tissue
collection approach consisting of
inserting a very thin needle it's
usually 26 gauge need a little bit
bigger than the middle that's used to
draw blood that can be done with CT or
or ultrasound guidance but if the
lesions are palpable it can be done
without guidance once the needles in the
lesion it's moved back and forth several
times to allow cancer cells or other
cells in the example to travel via
capillary action of the needle once the
cells are we don't have
of the needle we stop the procedure and
then the material can be processed and
either smeared on glass slides or
expelled into a test tube so fnl final
aspiration method is a preferred method
for sampling lesions that have a prone
to bleeding like Tyra lesions and for a
tissue collection from patients who have
advanced disease or who are not not good
candidates for more aggressive
procedures so once we obtain material by
final aspiration we can either as I
mentioned before smear it on glass
slides the slides are fixed and stained
either with Papanikolaou stain or
another stain which we called if quick
or minovsky Papanikolaou stain allows us
to analyze the the cell no claim of you
are detailed in very well while diff
quick stain allows us to analyze the
cytoplasm and the background the
material can also be expelled into the
test tube and then fixed either with
cytology fixative which is usually mix
of car barracks and ethanol kai PO Boxes
polyethylene glycol alternatively in
some instances the sample can be also
fixed in formalin once the tissue injury
in the tube is fixed then it's embedded
in paraffin to create cell blocks and no
suboxone sections and stained with H&E
like any other surgical the samples will
be so why is it important to do
molecular testing and why do we need to
do it I want to do it from psychology
material well molecular diagnostics is
extremely important for patient
management in particular to decide the
extent of surgery how much did she needs
to be excised and to determine which
targeted therapies are available for
particular patient in particular
clinical situation
and why we would like to do this from so
I told you well they're certainly shins
that otherwise would not be accessible
such as our dimension thyroid me region
started model or any other sites that
are prone to heavy bleeding metastatic
lesions are often sample by psychology
and also psychology the set illogical
approach is a suitable for patients who
cannot tolerate more aggressive approach
with other comorbidities and some
patients simply do not want to be
subject to their aggressive tissue
collection of protocols so currently the
College of American Pathologists
recommends that all tissue or molecular
testing from psychology is done on cell
blocks and this is done because of the
fear that diagnostic material on the
slides would be used up and nothing
would be left for them in their car and
the archive so how is the molecular
testing done on cytology cell blocks
well they're prepared as I mentioned
before and then there are sections in
five to eight sections the first section
is stained with HIV and examined by
pathologist for the areas that are
suitable for molecular testing and the
subsequent slides are then transposed
and the areas that corresponds to the
design of the air this chosen by
pathologist is microdissected and then
used to extract RNA or DNA however this
using this approach we encounter often
insufficient cellularity so then
returning to smear survivors so usually
we have more than one diagnostic smear
is usually a little a couple at least
five or or even more so it's perfectly
feasible and ok to save one or two
smears in the
archives and you with the rest for
molecular applications actually my
clinical practice I often encounter
situations in which I don't have enough
tissue on the cell block however I have
multiple smears with agnostic material
and I can use that five of them we leave
one or two to obtain data that are
necessary for patient management however
I cannot do it at a moment the moment
patients often refuse to get additional
samples so they left without without a
proper management so the objective of
our study was to assess the feasibility
of using different or also called
romanovsky and Papanikolaou states at
illogical smears from molecular
diagnostic studies of lung non-small
cell carcinomas for each of our key
areas mutation and EML for elk
translocation and also to study
communications in papillary thyroid
carcinomas a particular video a
communication I will now go over more
detail why we chose these lesions and
why we chose these mutations but before
that I just want to briefly go over the
advantages of molecular testing using
psychologist years these the adventures
and advantages are listed here so if we
use psychology smears we ensure that a
sample that that we sent for molecular
studies is representative of the tumor
of the region the cytology fixative is
alcohol and it's milder than formalin
introduces less operations and less it
was less with less questionable than
that informally and also when you renew
smears thats Mirza quarrel example can
be used for metastatic disease we can
use it on sample that you already have
we already have the clip of or
Papanikolaou prepared smear so we don't
have to do any additional tissues
which is beneficial for patients and our
turnaround time is much faster we wanted
today is supposed to ten days or two
weeks so again lesions testicle polanco
operations are long adenocarcinomas to
assess available targeted therapies and
thyroid lesions to determine the extent
of surgery so longer than a carcinomas
belong to a group of lesions that's
called non-small cell carcinomas lung
carcinomas comprise the majority of
these nations fifty-five percent in some
studies even more seventy percent the
other major region that belongs to this
non small-cell category in squamous
carcinoma so here on the right you can
see that each of these subtypes have a
distinct set of mutations adenocarcinoma
the most communication under carcinoma
is Kara's here shown in yellow in the
upper right corner the second most
common is egfr followed by a
translocation so we are focusing on
adenocarcinomas because they're most
common lesions sample by cytology most
commonly seen in our practice and we are
focusing on the three most common
mutation so here I'm going to go over
the little bit of details about the
mutations which we are testing so Karis
is present in fifteen to thirty percent
of non-small cell carcinomas
adenocarcinomas and in particular point
mutation involving cotton 1213 461 this
point mutations impaired entrancing GDPs
activity of chaos which renders the
chaos and constitutively active it keeps
GDP band and it keeps firing to the
downstream downstream signal signals k
rest is downstream of egfr and
they're for refractory to egfr tyrosine
kinase inhibitors so if the lesion is
positive color for k-rod it would not be
suitable for treatment with tyrosine
kinase inhibitors in the egfr the second
mutation is EGF are ninety percent of
these mutations comprise snow in frame
deletions of X and 19 or point mutation
in exon 21 this renders EGF receptor
hyperactive or constitutively active and
these mutation air mutations are
sensitive to tyrosine kinase inhibitors
and they prolong a progression free
survival typically to 14 to 16 the last
mutation that we tested in lung is our
translocation is present in five percent
off of tumors this is actually a fusion
protein that's composed of anaplastic
lymphoma kinase catalytic domain fused
to promoter from EML for their for the
public domain is overexpressed these
tumors with our consultation respond to
result in it which is a small molecule
inhibitor just a few words about Egypt
our receptor EGFR is transmembrane
tyrosine kinase receptor which gets
activated upon ligand binding and
dimerize and this induces the catalytic
activity of the intracellular part and
as you can see here on the slide all the
mutations that we are testing or
actually present in the catalytic domain
so on once Egypt our receptor is
activated and caduceus it induces cell
proliferation differentiation volatility
and survival so patients with tumors
that have Egypt or mutation are most
common
female as you can see here on the slide
highlighted in red their patients who
met majority of these patients never
smoked and of course majorities to have
lesions that are classified as
adenocarcinoma now a few words about
Kyra chaos is a membrane-bound GDP a
it's a downstream signal from egfr
receptor it's a constitutively active
and when mutated no telecommunications
as I mentioned already I in em united
opposition to 12 13 and 61 patients who
have Kara's my patients frequently have
frequently associated with smoking they
are also frequently of African American
ancestry and chaos just like egfr is
associated with cell growth for
liberation and differentiation again few
words about EML email elk this is a
cytoplasmic fusion protein composed of
EML promoter and catalytic domain of out
it is associated again is proliferation
and metastasis and tumors that have this
email translocations are usually young
males who never smoked end of asian
ancestry ethnicity so now we know about
seven variants of pml avocado
translocation and insert citation
towards with its location again are
sensitive through tyrosine kinase
inhibitor of result in it switching
briefly to thyroid carcinomas most
common carries carcinomas are made out
of Alba follicular cells the most common
cancer its popularity carcinoma
comprising up to eighty percent of
thyroid cancers the second most common
is follicular personal non comprising
about ten percent and there are two
other cancers that are really rare
medullary carcinoma
which is composed of rich [ __ ] accounts
for about five percent of cancers and a
very very rare and a plastic-coated Emma
so we focused our study on thyroid
carcinomas because their most common and
be focused on the analysis of most
communication and thyroid popular
carcinomas even see here it's be wrath
so we focus on a particular b-raf
mutation which is v600e which is a
substitution of valiant to lieutenant at
the residual 600 this mutation this
particular mutation is associated with
extranodal extension thyroid extension
positive nose distant metastasis and it
turns out to be independent predictor of
treatment failure and tomorrow so again
to summarize we looked at lung
adenocarcinomas and thyroid gravatar
carcinomas and retested EGF point
mutations in exon 20 21 and in prime
division title 19 cameras point
mutations in poems 12 13 and 61 mema EML
of four electrons location an imperative
we focused on papillary carcinoma and
erf v600e point mutations our study was
approved by our local amount of your n
stein RB and the cases were selected
from the archives of department of
pathology and we only worked with cases
that had multiple snares so that was
enough tissue remained in our oracle
archives we collected 31 long
adenocarcinomas 21 tafid I thyroid
carcinomas 18 were classic variant and
six world follicular variant and we also
had to follow her thyroid carcinoma as I
mentioned earlier these are rather rare
so now I will give this to dr. Goswami
who will continue the presentation he
will describe in detail pathology
they've used to detect the molecular
operations that I just outlined so in
order to better understand this process
this slide outlines a critical need of a
pathologist to look at the region in the
sphere where there are good cells which
can be interrogated by molecular
diagnostic methods this is this is
important because in the smear there are
some cells which are good and there are
small shock some small cells which are
necrotic so it is important for someone
to look at those slides and identify the
good cells which we can now further
interrogate for molecular diagnostic
purposes so basically what we do is a
pathologist identifies the region in the
sphere which is usable for molecular
diagnostic testing and that part is
scraped out and put into this slide I
put into a tube while the rest of the
material is kept back in the archived
for future testing if needed so for the
r mutation detection we utilize the
technology called q clamp technology we
are from a company called dicota we
procure the reagents from them and we
utilized the clamp technology to
determine both single based mutations as
well as interim deletions that why I
just mentioned in this test the
uniqueness of this test is that while
performing real-time pcr the wild-type
component of the of the cells do not get
amplified the wild-type DNA does not get
amplified well as the mutant gets
amplified as is as is visible in the
amplification curve when there is no
plan there is there is
a decent PCR reaction giving rise to a
good amplification curve whereas if you
put wild-type a DNA and offer the clamp
there will be there will be no pcr
product form this is absolutely
important for working with a small
number of cells and particularly once
which have a smaller number of cells
which are mutant case in point in C in
the gold standard sequencing today there
you need to have at least four hundred
cells which are armed available for
molecular diagnostic testing and out of
them ten percent which is about 40
serves over 400 should be notation
positive for them too convenient before
but then to convincingly say that it is
mutation positive in our case using this
technology we've been able to achieve
much better we can detect are as few as
50 cells a single cell which is mutant a
naturalist 50 cells can be expected by
this technology this I believe is a big
improvement over the current arm you
know word standard method of sequencing
so going over to the technology that we
used for the ml for ALK translocation we
used a process for a process of qrt-pcr
and we design primers to clear the
primers one in the five prime end and
one in the three prime end and we
perform qpcr from the FNS mere or salmon
extracted from the Venice news you do
remember Maya mention that the F&A
smears are stained are fixed with
alberto as opposed to paraformaldehyde
alcohols fixed ourselves are much more
much better for iron extraction and
people working with that the FFPE
samples are used to be stained with I
usually fixed with a formaldehyde or
formaldehyde this causes the RNA to get
degraded as anybody who works in the
field knows that if FP RNA is often
degraded and very difficult to work with
on the other hand English spheres which
have been fixed with alcohol we were
able to get fairly good quality
RNA from as few as 50 cells and we were
able to look at the translocation by
looking at the qrt-pcr on those samples
so the process here is a we have two
sets of primers one in the five prime
end and one in the three prime end and
in a wild-type sample where there is no
Miletich when they wear that is where it
though there is no translocation usually
we don't get any signal because normal
lung or not normal are in tissue do not
express arm ALK at all so only in those
samples where there is an EML for ALK
translocation we would see a and ALK
expression and that too only in the
three prime end the five prime end will
not be visible so there by looking at
the two curves of the amplification
curves we can determine a wild-type
sample which has some alka expression
and a milliner translocated sample which
has a larger amount of the three prime
end of the area sample again using this
technology we were able to detect as few
as 50 cells in a smear and have s 30 50
cells in a smear and as few as a single
cell in that 50 cell containing the
translocation so now to expand this a
little further for the air the top two
panels a and B described the mutation
detection whereas the bottom two panels
CNT describe the translocation detection
so going back to the q clamp technology
once we utilized the Q clamp technology
we were able to see the difference if
you if you look at the panel be in palin
panel be there was a muted serve em a
neutral sample and in panel a there was
a non-mutant wild-type sample so in the
wild-type sample the clamp and no clamp
have more than 10 CT difference whereas
in the sample that had the mutation
there was about four to five city are
difference similarly if you look at the
panel at the bottom and the panel at the
bottom which is c and d DC is wild type
reference RNA where the difference is
that you see in the three prime in the
five prime primer
due to primer efficiencies whereas the
morgue intensity difference is observed
between the three prime in the pipeline
peaks from the y prime curves in example
that has the translocation using this
methodology we were able to do to detect
like I said before we were able to
detect as few as 50 cells are bearing a
single mutant of Alaska patient are
located some now are going back to early
to the technologies once again the in
the MV wild-type in the wild-type DNA
when the DNA polymerase is extending the
forward primer at the three prime end if
there is an XNA probe which has a
hundred percent match with a wide type
sequence there will be no pcr product
form whereas in the Newton DNA where the
XNA probe does not match very well even
with a single base pair difference it
will not fit very well and they're real
amplification product so this is the
basics basis of the cube clamp
technology which we used in our work
another plan at the bottom in prob NP we
have the idea of designing to play eye
primers two sets of primers one end up
sweet prime end very close to the poly a
tail of the mRNA and one at the five
prime end away from the arm from the MLK
fusion site the fusion side is marked
with an arrow and like my I mentioned
there are about of six to seven
different kind of fusion proteins that
are known so utilizing this technology
we were able to identify all of them
however one of the weaknesses of our
technology in both the mutation
detection and transportation is that we
are unable to find out what the mutation
precisely is we just know the presence
or absence and the same for
transportation we know that it is either
present or absent and I call Maya can
tell is better to you that currently the
actual nutation does not determine what
drug differences will be given same with
the translocation okay
so i think i will give this over to
doctor doctor to continue with the
results section thank you so um so I
will go over the results the results of
our study will appear soon in the
journal of molecular diagnostics so if
you want to go through this in detail I
would refer you to that publication so
this slide summarizes the clinical and
pathological characteristics of our
corporate lung adenocarcinoma cohort in
the under B you can see that the average
patient age was 70 so they were quite
all patients most of them were women 61
percent average tumor size was quite
large four centimeters many patients
seventy-four percent of them had local
metastases and more than half of them 58
and distant metastases as well and out
of this 31 patients we detected 80 in
eighty percent of them we detected
mutations the next slide summarizes in
detail the mutation that we found so in
the left part of the of the table shows
the mutations that were found by
sequencing in the reference laboratory
EGFR mutation chaos as well as a female
attention education that was detected by
fish and the right part of the table
shows the results from our laboratory so
I would like to emphasize that when we
compare our results with reference
laboratory that was one hundred percent
concordance rate we detected all the
mutations that were detected by the
reference laboratory however we detected
additional mutations for example if you
look under page
number for the reference laboratory
detected mutation in key areas in called
called own 12 and we detected that one
and in addition we detected egfr
mutations in exhausted 19 and 21
similarly probation 5 there was no
mutation detected by reference
laboratory and we detected communication
k ransom call the twelve and so forth
locations 13 17 18 19 25 28 and 30 so
this was rather interesting to us and
invented and it important it indicates
that our technology is is a bit more
sensitive than what's out there right
now so another interesting point that I
want to mention here is that we detected
several mutations in the single tumor
and so fine literature has been
published that that the mutations are
need to be exclusive in other words if
there's a mutation in the agent in egfr
they will know a limitation in kos
however we have three cases here in
which we found a mutation in egfr CO 2
19 and chaos code 12 and then we also
had two cases in which we found mutation
in chaos 112 and also translocation an
EML and one case in which require front
three electrode alterations we found
Egypt our vacations occurred on 19 and
21 mutation and also mutation carriers
corner 12 so here's the summary of the
comparison between our laboratory and
reference laboratory our laboratory in a
referencing V and collect comparison see
so you can see here that we detected
more each of our mutations than the
reference laboratory we detected
41-percent mutations while reference
laboratory detected 19 the percentage of
mutations detected for care has its
similar between our laboratory and
the you reference laboratory and so is
the email translocation so if you look
at sea there are no cases that were
positive in reference laboratory and
negative in our laboratory however there
are quite a few cases that were negative
in reference laboratory and positive in
our lab returned now switching to a
thyroid cohort here's the summary of the
cohort average age was younger as
expected I was 52 also is expected to
that it was more women which usually
have more regions in men too much
smaller than line was two centimeter and
we saw as expected more papillary
thyroid carcinomas than follicular
cancers papillary thyroid cancers
classical variant with over sixty-five
percent and the follicular where 27 and
only eight percent were follicular
cancers again in this cohort also really
texted there was a hundred percent
concordance between us and the reference
laboratory where were we did not send
many samples to reference laboratory
send seven samples five of which were
positive in reference laboratory in our
laboratory and tor- interesting point to
mention here is that we detected the
mutations in the RAF in eighty-one
percent of cases which is significantly
higher than reported in literature in
literature the mutation rate reported is
50% so to summarize qpcr clamp method is
suitable for mutational analysis and
translocation analysis for both pair
innovative tissue as well as
psychologists smears we applied it
successfully and obtain high sensitivity
we obtained 1% mutation detection level
in a spurious 50 cells which is much
more significant compared to what's used
in reference laboratory today
they need 400 cells and with the
temperature mutation rate we detected
more of Iraq mutation anyone eighty-one
percent compared to the reference
laboratory and we also detected ninety
percent more I don't know carcinomas
with with other mutations more than we
understand however also would like to
find certain limitations and no problems
but certain things that we need to pay
attention to the so our method is ultra
sensitive method we detect mutations
that are present in minority of self is
varied yourself so if one would try to
treat patients based on based on the
mutation that's present in very small
proportion of cells one may not find
clearly when this may not be clinically
detectable so the response to targeted
therapy may not be clinically detectable
however this small proportion of cells
may be a seed for future development of
to them for for recurrence let's say
that way so that's why College of
American Pathologists or cap recommends
that use two tier testing strategy in
which we will first apply the standard
standard technology which detects
mutations in ten percent of cells not
less than that and then apply also
highly sensitive methodology to be alert
on potential sub population of cells
that have other mutations for potential
future testing or future therapies so
the final conclusion qpcr clamp
technology and qrt-pcr approach can be
successfully used to detect targetable
mutations from psychological smears of
lung and thyroid carcinomas and this
approach represents an ultra sensitive
technology which will be increasingly
needed as small amounts of diagnosis of
material and mutations in minority of
cells with the tumor become available so
i would enemy that and we open local
questions thank you
thank you for that informative
presentation i'm julia child of lab
roots and I will be moderating the
following question and answer session
before we get started I would like to
tell our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them into the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as you can our first
question is do you consider this
technology better so we're trying to
arrange so we can both ends your
questions so here's dr. goswami yeah
definitely like I mentioned in the in
the talk and I believe that this
technology is definitely very helpful
because our previously many of the
patients could not benefit from this
benefit from this approach whereas today
we're with this technology they should
many people pretty much all the patients
can benefit from our we do molecular
diagnostic approach don't you see so
perhaps i can add to this in my practice
I often see cases in which we don't have
enough tissue in the cellblock really
often we have enough on smears and I get
calls from treating physicians to to
assess mutational status which I cannot
so I have to go back to them and say we
need additional tissue and then a
patient's refuse to have another
procedure so that happened multiple
times so if i can use several of my
smears and send them to my artistic that
will be extremely extremely useful
patients who would be able to get
diagnosis and they would be able to get
targeted treatments that are now not
available for them
because there's a material and they're
not a degraded they don't want to have
additional procedures for sometimes
they're comorbidities and they just came
up cannot tolerate additional procedures
I hope that answers your question the
next question did you test all those
mutations in one multiplex reaction with
cute mutt cramp or in individually which
would use more DNA so for the time being
we have done all of these individually
because we this is more of a proof of
principle kind of an experiment but at a
later date we do plan to go multiplex
though our multiplexing them will have
its own set of complex issues but right
now we have all done only them
individually however we have used a very
sensitive methods of you know qpcr and
very small volumes and in order to go
down to the number of sevens that we
have used yes but for now we've only
used single well control do you use to
make sure the negative and wild type is
not a false negative in a positive
sample of Q crap okay for controls and
asthma as dr. mentioned in our paper we
have used cell lines that are known to
have mutations and cell lines that are
no not to have mutations since it's a
hundred percent of nearly hundred
percent population of the cells either
bearing or not bearing the mutation we
have used them as controls both positive
and negative in our arm test in order to
determine the false positive and the
false negative status well yeah we
diluted the cell lines with arm the
mutant positive cell lines with the
nutrition negative cell lines and use
them as controls
having used coupon with liquid biopsy
samples yeah we have not personally done
this but dicot and the company from whom
we have bought the reagents they have
performed some experiments and I have
heard that it's working in liquid biopsy
and they would be publishing it soon but
we are we have not done this week we
tend to focus on the smears because as I
mentioned in the talk if you take the
fna directly there would be a lot of you
know degraded cells and there will be a
lot of you know necrotic tissue and we
wanted to make sure that we are working
with good quality material so we wanted
to stick to the smears where somebody
has looked at it under the microscope
and marked regions where the cells are
good so we wanted to focus on that but
like I mentioned the company has done it
there are no more questions I would like
to thank again dr. West mommy and dr.
often ignore their presentation you have
any final comments no I think thank you
very much for listening and I believe
that this technology we will be able to
take it further and hopefully someday
soon it will be available for clinical
practice yeah same thing I completely
concur with dr. Goswami I'm hoping to
say that in clinical practice very soon
it will be extremely helpful and many
many patients would benefit thank you
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand movies you six months from the
light day you will receive an email from
lab reads alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward this announcement to come
to man with today's lab
see you next time and goodbye